let's get started
so today we're gonna look at one of my
favorite puzzles I'll say right at the
beginning that the coding associated
with the puzzle is fairly
straightforward but the analysis
associated with this puzzle is quite
intricate and in particular if you're
gonna have to do worst-case analysis
which is really a good thing to for you
to learn about because asymptotic
analysis in algorithms is all about
worst case alright so keep that in mind
when you try to come up with answers to
my questions always keep in mind that
I'm going to be asking for what happens
in the worst case know in the context of
our puzzle which is is called the
crystal ball puzzle and it's fairly
popular in the literature though I've
generalized it a little bit you have the
situation where you're supposed to
figure out the hardness coefficient of a
crystal ball and in the generalized
version you have a set of identical
crystal balls right so how do you find
this hardness coefficient well you go up
to this Shanghai tower that has 128
floors one through 128 and you drop this
ball from say floor one so just you're
standing here and let's say you just
drop it from there or you go up to floor
to and you drop the ball and the
hardness coefficient is defined as the
highest floor from which you can drop
the ball and the ball does not break
okay so what this means is if floor F
the ball doesn't break
and it breaks at f+ 1 then the hardness
coefficient is F and you can assume a
monotone a city properly that says that
if it did not break at floor F then it
won't break this implies that it won't
break it at any floor less than or equal
to F okay which makes sense right
I'm not otherwise it would be kind of
complicated it would be random and
everyone be able to do any interesting
analysis um so the easy a version of the
puzzle of course which is not
particularly interesting is if you need
it to get this this exactly right so
your job depends on getting that number
exactly right so there's no shortcuts
you got to get it right you can't be off
by one either way and I you I have only
one ball right so you only have one ball
so so what can you do if you only have
one ball and you have to get it exactly
right
try every floor right and and but more
important I try from lower floors to
higher floors right so you drop it at
floor one I saw one ball you drop from
floor one and if it in and if it breaks
then your hardness coefficient is is you
return zero but then if you keep going
and it and it let's say you drop I've
got a dot from floor 65 and it breaks
and you've gone in order then the
hardness coefficient is 64 okay right so
that's easy enough there's there's no
optimization here it's the only thing
you can do so that's why it's not
particularly interesting now if you have
identical crystal balls that are
guaranteed
they were manufactured in exactly the
same way
etc etc then obviously things get a lot
more interesting because you can try to
minimize something and I'm gonna write
it over here because I want you to keep
this in mind throughout the lecture our
goal here is to minimize the worst case
number of drops for our problem and if
we want to we want to solve the problem
in the general case with the balls and I
should say D identical balls but more
important the reason I'm writing this up
is as I said before we need to focus on
the worst case right so it may be the
case that for a given set of balls your
algorithm does very well I in in in the
sense that the hardness coefficient
happened to be 42 and you you picked the
floor as as of 41 to begin with and so
you drop from 41 and it doesn't break
and then you go to 42 and it doesn't
break and you go to 43 and it doesn't M
it breaks and you go oh I only needed
two drops for this particular problem
but but if you but if the hardness
coefficient happened to be a 65 and you
started from floor 41 I mean you need 20
odd number of drops right so you have to
be careful I in that you have to analyze
whatever strategy you come up with I in
the case where the hardness coefficient
could be pretty much anything I mean it
could be zero or it could be 128 all
right I'm not a Shanghai Tower example
all right so the first interesting
question is what happens when I have two
identical balls right so oh before we do
that
according to according to my metric here
what is the worst case
number of drops for one ball what is the
worst case number of drops for one ball
give me a number
someone else yeah back there 128 exactly
right so it's it's 128 because I could
have had a ball that doesn't break from
the 128 floor I don't know that to begin
with I have to start with floor 1 and I
gotta go 1 2 3 4 etc right so the worst
case for one ball is 128 and then you
can't do better than that alright it but
of course it gets more interesting when
D is large right so so our goal now is
to discover an algorithm that is going
to minimize the worst case number of
drops for D equals 2 okay that's that's
our that's our current goal right and
then we'll look at more even more
general things so how would you do if
thinks if you had D equals 2 right it
just it doesn't matter if you don't get
the algorithm right I'll let me analyze
it you propose something you'll analyze
it and then we'll decide if we can do
better or not yeah go ahead
Oh use the bottom half excellent what's
your name sorry Domon um and so so so
Domon says that we should do binary
search right which is very intuitive and
kind of make sense in a lot of context
including this one and so let's drop
from sorry from 64 and the reason she
picked that is because 128 divided by 2
is 64 and if it breaks then I you need
to look at the interval 1 comma 63 right
because it if it I'm sorry if it yeah
that's right if it if it breaks you you
need to look at the interval 1 comma 63
with the second ball I mean that that
first ball is gone okay it shards of
crystal or whatever you want to call it
um so so you just have the second ball
and so now at this point you have no
choice
alright you only have one ball left
right as I mentioned your job depends on
getting that hardness coefficient right
so you can only use that first algorithm
in terms of starting from 1 and going
all the way to 63 and so what is the
worst case number of drops given that
diamond picked the midpoint for this
algorithm someone else yeah go ahead
it's succeed 63
no actually it's you're off by one
because I did drop the ball here right
so so close so I first ball I was
dropped once one drop and at this one if
in fact you at the hardness coefficient
was 64 you drop the second ball 62 63
times and that would be the worst case
in the in this instance now I've skipped
over one little thing at the fact that
this is the midpoint implies that this
is in fact the correct answer but we do
have to analyze I mean remember you know
when you do analysis you do have to
cover the entire spectrum here so you do
have to Kate it look at the case where
the drop from 64 it does not break okay
and in that case you're looking at
looking at 65 through 128 but you do
have two balls for this right it didn't
break so you still have two balls for
that right and so you can imagine that
now that you have two balls and you have
a small interval that you're going to be
able to do something like 32 for that
the bottom line is you don't even need
you can get a little bit lazy here you
don't really need to analyze what the
number is because you know that this
number 63 plus 1is is larger than that
right because you want it worst case
right so this is the kind of thing that
you have to do when you do algorithmic
analysis maybe not exactly if I in in a
puzzle situation like this but you have
to look at all the cases right then you
have to find kind of the max of all the
cases right so is this the best you can
do yeah go ahead
yeah
every 16
30 seconds you have to only test
that's correct yeah I mean this is
obviously there's not gonna be a whole
lot of optimization here but V equals
two but you'd be surprised as to how
much better you can do then 64 which is
obviously a big step forward from 128
but you can you can go a few more steps
as well and so what was your name Lucy
so Lucy has it right you it's it's a
similar idea except you don't
necessarily need to do the intuitive
binary search it's actually kind of
different from that because of the way
this problem is structured and what her
idea is is that we'll we look at
something smaller a smaller interval
okay and that she picks 16 so let's go
1632 sour algorithm is something that
goes 16 32 48 64 that a dot and you know
maybe gets up all the way to I guess six
yeah 128 and 16 16 is a it's 128 is a
multiple of 16 right some some math
person tell make sure I'm right so so
you have so what happens here so let's
analyze this and to make sure that we're
good in terms of an improvement right we
have to be careful so let's just
arbitrarily say that it broke it's 64
okay because that's kind of what
happened over in that previous algorithm
to so that means I've done four drops
without a break right I'm sorry four
drops three drops without a break and
four drops total right um so I've done
four drops but now the cool thing is I
don't have to start from 16 I can Stein
oh it didn't break at 48 right so so I
can I can now look at 4 drop still break
a first-ball
that is what I wanted to say and now I
need I can look at the interval 48 49
because 48 it did not break right 49 to
63 inclusive right and so if you do that
that's 15 it's 15
the difference is 14 but it's inclusive
so it's 15 so 15 plus 4 right there is
19 drops all right
yeah yes that's absolutely correct so so
19 is not the worst case I mean it is
looking good but this was exactly the
point I was trying to make right from
the beginning you're not done yet I mean
you cannot just go off and say that 19
is the worst case for this algorithm the
worst case for this out this particular
algorithm occurs at a different point
from the original algorithm that went
Midway right every algorithm is
different the parameters are are
different here and so I'm just calling
it a different algorithm but the the
case that would happen is I guess you'd
have 112 here and then you'd go 1 2 so
how many so let's say it gets to 128 and
if it doesn't break then you're clearly
done so that's not the worst case right
so if it gets to 128 and it and it
breaks then so how many drops have we
done 128 divided by 16 is what is 8 are
you sure you're all sure ok then I'm
sure so that's 8 drops and now you need
to do 113 to 127 and that we know is 15
so that's 23 all right so so the best
you've done here is it's 23 right but
I'll be satisfied we're never satisfied
right you always want to do a little bit
better okay so so how did she pick 16
why did you come up with 16 losing it
looked like a nice number
you just figured oh nice okay so so so
if you had 17 then we would have real
trouble right with all these numbers
yeah go ahead
beautiful beautiful I love you guys
you guys make it so easy so that's the
next thing I was going to try and pry
out of you but you got it out without
much effort from me so you can you can
kind of get analytical here as opposed
to doing things and particularly which
was you know try a number and figure out
what happened which is kind of what we
did and you can be a little more
analytical about this and you could say
hey I'm suppose I want to find this
number K which is kind of the 64 started
with 64 went to 16 and now we're
thinking we can do better than 16 even
and we start dropping things at K 2 K 3
K and I want to get this exactly right
so let me look at my notes and you go
dot a dot n divided by K minus 1 times K
and n divided by K times K which is
obviously M and so I I'm trying to I'm
trying to write it and I'm trying to get
this K I want to write something I want
to minimize some quantity and discover
the K that is going to give me my best
case in the worst case okay minimize the
worst case right so that's that's really
what I want so so if you look at what
what happens here you're you're in a
situation where you have to now you have
to count right I mean what do you want
to I decided that that K is this general
strategy and we don't quite know what K
is and we have to do some analysis of
the worst-case situation in order to
find the K that would work well for us
and so the way you do this is by
essentially the analysis we've done so
far and
kind of we have a nice the the the point
that was made here I think was it was
Kevin who said we have to go to the last
drop because that's kind of the the case
where I it's the worst case and that's
similar here as well because if you go
up all the way here and then it breaks
if it doesn't break here you're done
if it breaks here then you've got you've
done a lot of drops before it broke that
first ball and so that's at the
situation which you can pull them as
your worst case situation right so
that's exactly what we did before and so
so if you really think about it the
assumed first ball doesn't break till
the last draw is the is the worst-case
situation right and so what does that
mean
from a symbolic standpoint with respect
to the number of drops of so so the
number of drops in this case of the
first ball can someone give me an
equation for it yeah okay you're Kevin -
yeah okay so so n over K right so so
that's the that's what happened there
now well it broke right that's what we
decided here and so now you need to
search and K plus 1 right
- I bet you got to go all the way there
I'm sorry it broke there so you got to
go n minus 1 is the same as what I wrote
before in but it's just that I had
numbers and it was kind of easier to
write numbers then write these symbols
but we have to do this because we don't
know what K is okay so the if you look
at the how many
drops are and if you guys can do this
you get a if you notice this gets
simplified to and yeah so this is n then
you have minus k plus 1 all the way to n
minus 1 right so if you subtract and
this is a plus 1 here boy
this is confusing I'm not good at math
I'm definitely not good at math so this
is K minus 1 drops in the worst case
alright so you now need to add these two
things together so what we'd like to do
is minimize and my n divided by K which
is this Plus that right we want to
minimize this function right n its
constant K is a variable right and we
know for a given n we want to discover
the K that minimizes this quantity and
it goes back to the intuition that that
I think Josh had about the square root
of n right
so again high school calculus here which
I've forgotten is hopefully you haven't
because you still need it I don't and
you end up essentially saying you can
turn this into 2 raised to square root
of n minus 1 drops in the worst case all
right
so 4 so you can take that the floor of
that and that's that's 11 okay so so
that's the square root of n so 2 times
11 minus 1 is 21 so you can do 21
so you think 21 is the optimum yeah
yes yes you can you can do a little bit
better I don't want to do this yes yet
hopefully we'll have time we'll get to
that because I want to go to the the D
greater than two case but you're
absolutely right it turns out you can do
this would this would give you 21 as I
mentioned at 22 minus one I tell thought
you can do better by a few drops and the
assumption we made here
what is the assumption that we made here
but I wrote this what assumption did I
make which is kind of similar to what
Kevin just said but not exactly right
but someone point out the assumption
that was made here not you someone else
all right go for it
yeah the intervals are equal right so so
so I this look it's it's a different
problem if it didn't break here then I
got a smaller I have two balls and I had
a smaller problem so why would I use the
same K right I mean that kind of makes
sense right so now it's more complicated
and I hopefully will get to that but I
want to do other things first
so that's the reason so at least you
know why 21 isn't optimal right it's
because of this constraint that we
placed on ourselves in order to do this
analysis to get to the point where we
had two times square root of n minus one
that that corresponds to the equally
level constraint okay all right so good
all right any questions about this so as
you can imagine I'm not going to show
you code that computes two times square
root of n minus 1 right I said that that
doesn't make sense but we do have code
to look at that corresponds to at the
case where a D could be 3 D could be 4
and and then obviously it gets more
interesting in terms of what your
strategy is and we won't go with
optimizing in fact it's an open problem
as to what the optimum strategy would be
for arbitrary D in the D meaning the
number of balls if it's 5 6 whatever
partly because of what I just talked
about with respect to you need to
utilize unequal intervals but the
natural thing to do now is to move to D
equals arbitrary number of balls and
stick with kind of the same algorithmic
approach of having equal intervals right
and but the question is you know what
are these intervals what and how would
we find the size of these intervals
right because it's kind of not
immediately obvious if I told you D was
5 and you don't want to just keep the 3
balls away and you know sell them later
and just use the 2 right that doesn't
give you your minimum doesn't minimize
your worst case you want to use these
you use these balls cool all right so
let's
let's talk a little bit about if I had d
equals 3 I mean again gonna use your
intuition what do you think we should do
what happened for D equals 2 with
respect to that interval and how is it
related to n right so what do you think
I just wild guess maybe even what do you
think we need to do if he had d equals 3
for that very first ball in terms of
what we need to look at in relation to
the interval sighs yeah back there
ah-ha cube root cube root what what's
your name Ryan so Ryan says you know
cube root and yeah that that's the
correct intuition it's a little bit
unclear you know what happens you know
so they do cube roots and maybe you have
you know what's the cube root of 128 5
you know yeah that's right I think it's
5 ok it's close to 5 you know it's it's
say six or five or six right and and so
maybe I do six and then I do 12 and it's
that is it's a little bit strange so it
turns out it's actually the six in 12
when you start with 128 when you have
three balls doesn't seem like it's gonna
give you the worst case right right
because you know like in the worst case
you might be dropping the ball six 12 18
24 etcetera etcetera right um so cube
root is right but it's something a
little bit different because it gave us
this interval that was kind of too small
so how would I get something that's
bigger you'd want things that are a
little bit bigger right I mean yeah I
think you're going to the right
direction but I don't want six and
twelve and eighteen
I mean clearly that's going to give me
like 25 drops and that's even worse than
then then the two ball case which really
means you should lose your job and never
get another one right so if you do
something that bad right so so that
that's up to what what would you do
that's you know kind of different from
cube root but related to cube root right
yeah go ahead fun
yeah so what you want to do is you want
to start it makes sense that when you
have lots of balls in terms of being
able to use them that you start with
larger intervals and you shrink them
right that's exactly what happened with
two balls
you started with K I in in the case
where we had two balls and then we're
down to one when we have one ball right
so that's really what you're doing when
you have one ball all you can do is go
one floor at a time when you have when
you have two balls you go K where K
happened to be square root of n and then
we had three balls you kind of want to
start with with like n raised to 2/3 in
terms of the in terms of the interval
right and then if I had four balls the
argument would be that I would start
with n raised to three three quarters
and then I'll go to square root of N and
then I'll go so on and so forth and what
is that reminding you of well what is
what is this in terms of these powers
and you know getting up to not quite n
but five six N and so on what is that
reminding you of from number number
theory or just sort of regular
arithmetic yeah different bases it's
different different radix arithmetic
right so it turns out the way you want
to solve this problem and and this is in
keeping with the intuition you have you
you have with respect to the cube roots
and so on and so forth the way we want
to do this is we want to think about D
digit numbers and at the numbers
themselves and D is the number of balls
and so that's that D digits but what
what is the Vedic sub these numbers okay
the the radix of these numbers are going
to be related to that to the K to the
intervals right so you you you
essentially want to say you know I'm
counting in multiples of K right you
know I went K 2 K 3 K etcetera so if I
had like radix K that means I'm just
incrementing that particular particular
digit right you know 5 if I go if I had
radix 12 and
and I had one zero in radix 12 right
then you know this this this would be so
when I go to zero then at the the most
significant digit
I got incremented and so this this is
plus 12 this is 12 times larger I'm
sorry
12 larger then 2 0 is 12 larger than 1 0
in in in radix 12 right make sense just
like 20 is 10 larger than 10 10 in in
decimal right so so that's that's the
way you want to think about this and so
I you're gonna do our Airy numbers and
the first thing that you need to do is
you need to figure out based on the
number of floors that you have figure
out your given D you're given n the
number of floors and you're given the
number of balls you got to figure out
what radix you're working in and this is
going to be a generalization of the
square root of n as you'll see we we
want to choose the radix such that R
raised to D is greater than n I choose R
such that R raised to D is greater than
n right and so that comes back to
obviously if you need it if D where 2
then it makes sense that our would be
square root of M right which is in
keeping with what we talked about right
but if if D is 3 then that radix not
necessarily the interval that we choose
because the intervals are going to be
different it's going to be more like the
cube root of n which is also proposed
right Brian mentioned that and so so in
this case let's say that n were 128 and
D equals 4 then we would choose R equals
4 because 4 raised to 4 is 256 which is
greater than 128 and we can't use 3
because 3
raise to4 is only 81 and 81 isn't
greater than 128 right so you'd have to
choose four so so what we are now saying
is we want to somehow figure out if
you're not quite there at an algorithm
yet but we have a kind of a path forward
I in that we want to look at the
representation that our airy
representation of these digital numbers
and we're going to essentially I
increment and so with our goal
roughly speaking we're going to go with
this representation and we're going to
start incrementing digits so we just go
0 1 2 in terms of the digits but but
because the representation is our airy
that means something different in terms
of the number of floors depending on
what R is right I mean just like I said
um if this were if this were ternary a
ternary representation then then in
terms of floors this is only you know
this would be a 4 ternary this would be
3 floors to 0 the in to 0 would be 3
floors away from 1 0 right in decimal to
0 is 10 floors away from 1 0 and so on
and so forth that makes sense yeah ask
me questions if if you're confused um so
let's take an example so and then we'll
we'll look at that we look at code that
actually builds this algorithm from from
scratch so if we take our example of D
equals 4 for our canonical one 28th
floor Shanghai Tower because you do want
to get a sense of how things improve we
did improve from obviously D equals 1
through D equals 2 with the equal
interval assumption but with this radix
idea we'd like to see how much better we
can do right with D equals 4 and we
wanted is substantially better than then
21 drops or whatever we had back there
so so R is 4 D is 4 I'm sorry D is 4
n equals 128 and what we're going to do
is the smallest number is zero zero zero
zero and in in brackets I'm gonna write
you know what that decimal
representation is because I think that
does give you some intuition and you get
a sense of how this translates into into
floors and after after a while if you're
going to tell someone to do this you
want to give them floor numbers in
decimal because Shangai tower doesn't
have some weird
representation for the floors when you
get into an elevator or anything like
that so so this is floor zero and now
the highest number is 3 3 3 3 which
happens to be 255 I'm not gonna write
floor each time but when I put things in
brackets here that's the decimal
representation okay so that's 255 so
that's obviously too big we don't need
that but we're stuck with having to
choose r equals 4 for the reasons I
described to you before right so so
there's somewhere in here there's a
there's a 128 and I can't I don't have
it right up in front of me as to what
what 128 would correspond to but 1 2 3 3
for example would be floor 1 1 1 alright
so so the way this works and you all
know you're radix arithmetic it's a 3
times 1 plus 3 3 times 4 plus 2 times 4
square plus 1 times 4 cubed right that's
that's what you have and that's how you
get 1 1 1 so all what you have to do in
order to do this right is is to start
with the most significant digit which is
the leftmost digit and that makes sense
because we want our intervals when we
have lots of balls to be large and that
as you move and the balls break you're
going to start shifting rightward and
you're going to be incrementing
different things right and that's
essentially going to give us give us our
give us a round with them and so we'll
talk about let me just give you an
example of the algorithm
we'll if you look at we look at how the
algorithm is implemented as I mentioned
this it turns it into 10 lines of code
because all you're doing is translating
into this representation and you're just
incrementing bits of the representation
and it's interactive you can play with
it later today or whenever I ate and you
can't think of a hardness coefficients
in your head and see how things work out
but before we end we obviously have to
do a worst-case analysis of this of this
algorithm because that's the whole point
of this exercise so let's so so in this
case where do you think I should so I
don't want to drop obviously at floor
zero I mean that there's no notion of
that so very wide drop out at the
beginning the first drop is that given
what I told you you can tell me in any
any representation where would I drop
the first ball if I have four balls at
128 floors I said I want to start with
it's something that that obviously
there's some large interval here and I
want to I I want to start in the left
hand side and I want to increment the
leftmost bit which is the most
significant bit right so I would start
with 1 0 0 0 ok so the first drop is at
1 0 0 0 which is at floor 64 ok that's
the first row now if if in fact on this
this eye does not break all right so
let's assume that this does not break
then what do I do next
to 0 0 0 right and this would be 128
right ok let's assume that this breaks
here all right
so now what do I do it broke I lost a
ball now I have three balls left still
that's the good news and harmony so what
do I need where do I need to move if I
have 3 balls left I need to be in a
representation that has how many
digits three digits right so I need to
move III a broker mm so I know that it's
less than 2000 so I need to go back to
this because this is the this is the
highest floor in general whenever things
break you you go back to the highest
floor that you know that the ball been
break right I mean that's the canonical
strategy that we followed all through
when something when the ball breaks you
go back and say oh but I do know that
there was a highest floor in which the
ball did not break and I have to start
with one plus that right so so so what
I'm going to do here is I need to go up
and yeah because it broke I need to look
at one zero zero one
right the interval that I need to look
at is 1 0 0 1 right because it's one
more than that and all the way to 1 3 3
3 which is 1 less than that ok so and
this if this is you may feel a little
bit better looking at this in decimal I
certainly do it's 65 127 which makes
perfect sense so far we've played around
with with with the balls the first two
balls and so we haven't really seen
anything very dramatically different
from the the 2 ball case but more more
is coming right let's say this does not
break if this does not break then what
would I do now if it does not break I'm
sorry
my bad my bad
take I haven't even actually told you
I've just talked about the interval and
I haven't said what drop you need to
make right so so ignore what I said
right just now I think that the the next
question is the ball broke and I have a
second ball and I want the first drop of
the second ball all right
and I I want to look at this I want to
look at this interval and it has to be
we're inside this interval but it's not
going to be I'm not I'm not gonna drop
this at this floor sixty-five or one
three three three I want to I want to
pick something in between right and so
now looking at this
tell me according to what you know so
far where do you think I should drop the
second ball for the first time go ahead
96 and how did you get that you and you
put one one zero zero perfect
what's your name Evan so Evan says 96 I
guess he thinks in decimal you know
naturally like most of us but the the
way you would code this by the way is by
incrementing this digit okay and you'd
get one one zero one one zero zero and
in this case let's say it does not break
then I where you go Evan yeah after 96
it doesn't break what would you do well
it's in now in and in this
representation they did an easy it
whatever is easier for you perfect one
to zero zero which happens to be I think
112 so you go to floor 112 this was 96
all right and then you need to add
another 16 to that yep 112 and so on
right so I want I won't bore you with
this you get a sense of what's what's
going on here and obviously with these
things you can wave your hands and you
get a sense of what's going on but
ultimately you know what's great about
computer science and programming is
there's you got to teach the dumb
computer to do exactly the right thing
and there's no two things about it in
terms of you understand this algorithm I
didn't understand this algorithm until I
coded it fully right I mean maybe I
still don't understand it considering
the mistakes I'm making but this is
because I've lost a bunch of gray cells
so so let me let me show you what the
code looks like it's 15 lines of code
right it's not that much and as you can
imagine the the the representation is I
could have used many things I just used
a list for each of these digits I'm
incrementing these these digits and will
I want to spend a whole lot of time on
the code but what I want to do before we
end here is talk about actually let me
do that first before we we go to the
code I want to talk about the worst case
here right because that's all that's
what this is all about I want to get an
equation just like we did for two times
square root of n minus one and all of
these different things I want to get an
equation for the worst case in terms of
the number of drops in relation to R and
D which are obviously related to n right
because our raise to D has to be greater
than n right so if you kind of look at
this and it turns out this is not a
difficult analysis right if you if you
think if you think about it and you
start thinking about worst case and you
think about how we are incrementing
these things um these phases and if you
can think about a phase as as when a
better ball breaks you know that's when
a phase is done and you move to the
second phase right tell me I what how
many drops I have you break break it up
in terms of the number of phases right
or the number of balls whichever way you
want to think about it and use the same
kind of worst-case analysis we've done
with respect to what happens what
happens in the in the worst case you
have to keep you know doing a bunch of
drops and in really for these algorithms
the floor 127 the hardness coefficient
of of actually the hardness coefficient
of 127 was is this the hard one right
it's it's a difficult one because you
kind of go through and you go all the
way there and you do all of these things
before you drop a ball a lot of times
before it breaks and you do that for
every ball right that would be the worst
case right so that's kind of where
things are at so from a symbolic
standpoint what is the worst case in the
first phase in terms of the number of
of the first ball from a symbolic
standpoint right it's the first digit
I'm talking about it's the first ball
I'm talking about and I'm dropping this
ball as you can see at these different
points so in general how many drops
would I have
Minoo either I may be done completely
because it I know it doesn't break it
floor 128 or what I have you but what is
what is the worst case when that ball
breaks give me an equation someone
what's so I drop it once I drop it twice
and I am I going to drop it like like if
R is five am I gonna drop it ten times
I'm what am i doing in terms of the what
is the upper limit in terms of this this
digit our minus one and where am i
starting from one right so there you go
what's enough course answer our minus 1
right so that's it so it turns out that
I have R minus 1 drops in the worst case
for the first ball and I mean it's a
same representation every digit is the
same radix obviously right and now that
that ball broke and I moved to that to
the second digit with the second ball
and I'm gonna start again and in the
worst case I could have R minus 1 drops
with that as well right because I'm
gonna go increment from 0 the first one
I'm going to do is a 1 and then I'm
gonna do a two and all the way to R
minus 1 right so our minus 1 drops for
the second ball and then I go all the
way to D balls so so my answer
yeah go ahead yes you're absolutely
right that but if the if the number were
255 so one of the things that's
happening here is we have lost some
precision because our raise to D needed
to be this large number of 255 and this
algorithm is actually going to work for
255 floors all right
yeah because of em so so so it's not
yeah so that's kind of you know the it's
a good question you asked but
unfortunately you kind of want to choose
a case where you you have perfect
precision in terms of R raised to D is
exactly what you need it to be and in
that case this analysis works right yeah
that's the max n that does exactly right
so I mean 255 is substantially larger
than 128 so it kind of makes sense that
that as you said that you would be able
to shave off certain things right and so
you can kind of do that but it's a
little more involved but I think the the
intuition is important and the intuition
is simply that your worst case number of
drops assuming you're being a little bit
imprecise would simply be R minus 1
times D in the in the worst case and
this would be true for all n which is
less than R raised to D you know for all
n all right so it's a so now just in
terms of numbers I had R equals 4 and D
equals 4 and so you end up getting 12
drops for the 128th case all the way do
you know 255 as well
you need you need 12 drops in the worst
case even for 255 floors right which
which is really what you were asking
right so good all right that makes sense
yeah so I'm not gonna spend a whole lot
of time on this code but that's it
it
converting I could have used a Python
library function for that but that's
simply a conversion because I wanted to
print things out I don't even need that
this particular subroutine which is
essentially something that is doing
conversion from a decimal to do to our
arithmetic and as you can see you see a
subtract in and and adding the the the
adding is is the incrementation that I
just erased but you do see it up there
from 1 0 to 2 0 that's why you add
sometimes you need to subtract because
things break and when things break you
you need to go back to the to the
highest floor where the ball didn't
break right so that's where you you you
have you do the subtraction and so this
is how if you ran this this it's not the
greatest user user interface I'll admit
but that's not the point
so I'm gonna do 128 and 4 which is our
example
and he says radix shows in his ball 4
did the ball break I say no and then I
you know did they drop the ball did the
ball break if I say no here then I'm
done right so I'm gonna go ahead and say
yes and then I'm gonna say no and then
no I'm gonna keep going no no no because
this is the worst case and I got 11
right in this case so you do get closed
in in the sense that grata was asking
you know could you shave off you only
shaved off one because of the
imprecision so there is a case where
even though you would only get 12 for
255 but you do get 11 for 128 okay all
right cool
good so I'll let you look at the code if
you guys can again can leave anytime you
want I just wanted to mention I want to
go back to the one thing that I didn't
get that I mentioned but I haven't
gotten to which is this is still you can
still do better right you can still do
better
not because of what guna Tara mentioned
you know that's just that imprecision
thing but assuming even that was taken
care of because the numbers worked out
you can do better because K can be made
different you could do unequal intervals
right so let me put that into the in the
notes and you can read it by yourself
you had a question not even start asking
you or why did I start telling you where
like put a next ball drop because it
went one two and
and went also to ball three and ball
four I'm gonna just state ball - that's
that's because I'm lazy yeah
so it'd be a fine exercise to fix that I
mean it's not one of the it's not one of
the exercises that's how you turn you
know after 30 years of teaching whenever
I get a question I turn it into an
opportunity you know for homework okay
all right that's how it works
all right good see you guys next time